Частиною передвиборчої кампанії це бути не може,
тому що слова Богу Мюнхенські конференції не призначають під вибори в Україні.
Я намагаюся, коли нас запрошують,
завжди  приїжджати і спілкуватися з людьми,
які, власне, важливі для України,
і сьогодні особлива історія.
В Україні буде перезавантаження влади, я в цьому переконана.
В Україні буде новий президент.
І наша команда отримає нагоду зараз під час Мюнхенської конференції
поспілкуватися з ключовими лідерами для того,
щоб скласти бачення, як діяти після президентських виборів в Україні.
У нас буде зустріч з Крістін Лагард,
ому що для України співпраця з МВФ дуже важлива.
І ми хочемо вже зараз для всіх, хто з Україною співпрацює,
бути прогнозованими, щоб ми точно знали перший-другий-третій крок,
що робити в Україні після виборів президента.
Крім того, ви знаєте, що питання війни і миру для України ключове.
І сьогодні ми будемо бачити тих лідерів інших країн,
наприклад, ми сьогодні з президентом Естонії зустрічалися,
ми будемо бачитися з Куртом Волкером,
для того, щоб просто мати можливість обговорити ту нову дорожню карту,
ту стратегію миру і безпеки, яку пропонує наша команда.
Для нас дуже важливі ті дні, які ми можемом провести на Мюнхенські конференції.
Зараз в Україні все склалося дуже добре,
ому що всі ключові політичні сили
абсолютно чітко мають стратегію на інтеграцію в ЄС та НАТО.
І наша політична команда, наша політична партія,
з першого дня якраз сповідує членство України в ЄС.
Ну, а чим ми відрізняємося від Петра Олексійовича, це очевидно.
Тому що недостатньо лише декларувати, вступ в ЄС та НАТО.
Я вважаю, що діючий президент України
мусить бути головним провідником глибоких і реальних змін в державі.
І коли декларується вступ Україна в ЄС і НАТО,
треба дуже добре розуміти, що ці організації
будують свою роботу на цінностях,
а якщо зараз міжнародні структури
визначити Україну як найкорумпованішу державу Європи,
коли ми увійшли на останнє місце за рівнем бідності,
коли зараз ідуть вибори і вся країна говорить
про масовий підкуп голосів командою діючого президента,
і навіть тисячу гривень, яку роздають, назвали іменем президента,
це говорить про те, що саме нас відрізняє.
Ми хочемо глибоких, реальних змін
на основі цінностей ЄС та НАТО, куди ми прагнемо увійти.
А сьогодні, жаль, влада, яка є, вона не сповідує цих принципів
і не втілює їх у життя.
І тому дуже важливі реальні справи, а не пусті обіцянки.
Всім відомо, що для України будівництво "Північного потоку-1", "2"
це по суті, повністю руйнує інтереси України
з точки зору транспортування газу для потреб країн Європейського союзу.
І можу сказати, що саме незрозуміле для нас українців,
що в ціх потоках північних немає ніякої технічної потреби.
Україна може без будь-яких проблем забезпечити все транспортування
необхідного газу для європейських потреб.
і тому дуже прикро, що все це вирішується
без будь-яких консульитацій з Україною
і всуперед українським національним енергетичним інтересам.
Ви знаєте, що ми маємо угоду з Європейським союзом про асоціацію,
і там як мінімум три пунтки говорять про те,
що коли прицймаються такі рішення, то треба проводити консультацію з Україною.
і тому ми сподіважємося на те,
що все-таки будуть застосовані всі необхідні рішення,
для того, щоб не будувати політичні потоки,
а все-таки базуватися на економічній доцільності  і партнерстві.